hi there Steve Kaufman here again
talking about language learning as usual
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe to my channel today I want to
talk about meaningful input and how it
applies to my Greek learning okay
stephen krashen speaks of meaningful
input comprehensible input that
acquiring these meaningful messages
compelling input is basically how we
acquire languages how we get languages
into our brain so that we can then
subsequently produce them so for me
greek presents certain problems that i
haven't experienced in a while the when
i started on russian which is well over
it's got to be over ten years ago
russian then was the first sort of
language where most of the vocabulary
was unrelated to vocabulary that i had
from other languages
leaving aside chinese and japanese but
I'm saying you know German with English
English with French English with Spanish
there's a lot of vocabulary that you get
free when you get into Russian the
number of words that are identifiable is
much much less but then after doing
Russian then I did you know check
Ukrainian polish when I did Romanian of
course there's a lot of vocabulary that
that is similar to Italian but Greek
it's yeah there's some words you know
hora knows four time or homelesses color
photos light que photo there's some of
that but overwhelmingly the vocabulary
is new you got to learn it so it's
tougher for me then what I have been
experiencing over the last ten years or
so so I have we have our sort of
beginner stuff at link and then I got
onto these mini stories translating from
these English many stories and that was
a boon for me and I'm up to 40 of them
but we are short now of the the person
who's producing these in English seems
to have slowed down so before I get
further any further here if any of you
out there now we have all kinds of
volunteers translating these many
stories into 30 plus languages Arabic
Hebrew
I don't know Latvian and this is going
to be in public domain and so forth and
so on and I find these stories
tremendous from my Greek now I'm stuck
I've only I'm up to 40 so if any of you
in addition to those of you who have
volunteered to translate if you want to
create some stories all right then
following this formula the three-part
formula with lots of repetition using
largely high frequency verbs nouns don't
matter so much but verbs and we have
five levels so we now have level one
which is basically word order positive
negative question level two is the
different tenses level three we
introduced a concept such a purpose in
10th why because given the fact that
verbs of motion verbs of giving and
taking more work on tenses that's level
3 level 4 is probability necessity
possibility maybe doubt conditional
whenever those kinds of things and level
5 is where you want to express your
opinion in my view on the other hand it
would appear bla bla bla and more tenses
so there's five levels so that at each
level you can focus on practicing
patterns because don't forget this is
primarily about gaining initially some
familiarity with the patterns how
different languages express different
things and also as a place that you can
go back to to practice these patterns
and along the way you pick up some
vocabulary but they are vocabulary heavy
so for me and my Greek for example if I
look at a new lesson in our mini story
series there might only be 20% new words
whereas if I pull a newspaper article in
Greek there's 55% new words and it's
just hard it's hard especially because
there's no freebies if I'm into you know
polish from Ukranian 55% new words but a
lot of those words I'll know from
another Slavic language so I'm hoping
maybe again if some of you would
volunteer to write
so many stories for us in your own
language whatever that language is we'll
use it as learning material for that
language plus we would also like to get
the English translation so we could
translate it into other languages so we
start to accumulate this again in the
public domain collection of stories and
the advantage of having people write
these stories in their various native
languages is that we aren't too
culturally you know bound to essentially
in an english-speaking kind of cultural
environment so if any of you want to
write stories for us please let me know
here in the comment section or send me
an email at Steve at link ili ngq calm
and we'll get you in touch with zoar n
so we can get some more stories going in
this series but getting back to this
meaningful content doesn't so here I am
I right I find it too difficult to to
deal with 50 plus percent new words I
found a graded reader supposedly
folktales in Greek but I'm not that
interested in folktales it's okay and it
focus have a lot of vocabulary you know
the Fox
you know the crow stuff that's not
necessarily relevant to me one of the
best graded readers I ever had was in
Chinese 20 lectures on Chinese culture
which used use sort of a limited range
of vocabulary to talk about Chinese
history and Chinese culture
which is an interest of mine and
particularly in learning a new language
learning about a stirring the cultures
is very interesting so graded readers
are great I know
Oh Lee Richards is working on graded
readers for Spanish and so forth and of
course I want to find these wherever
they are
I'll buy the e-book put it through
caliber convert it into a format that we
could use a link imported into Lee and
start learning with it but having this
meaningful content is so important
because to step from these many stories
right up to the newspaper is too
difficult I think if I get to a hundred
minutes
Dory's I'll be a little further along
and nothing I wanted to mention - on
meaningful content we have the series at
link called who is she which is kind of
where I started with Greek and it was
very difficult for me very difficult but
now having done 40 of these many stories
I go back to who is she and it's a
delight it's a delight not only to see
words that you now know but also to
recognize the patterns I mean you're
going blind initially even though you
read an explanation of how they deal
with you know future whatever it is it
just flies by you but now that you've
experienced it through these stories
especially are many stories with all the
repetition and you have a sense of what
that means on how that pattern works and
then I go back to who is she and I see
those patterns and now it's just the
second nature common commonplace for me
it's it's it's a delight it's always a
delight to go back to some of the
material that you started with and now
see that in fact it's no longer
difficult for you anyway so just a
little bit of a discussion on the
importance of meaning comprehensible
input how we get that meaningful
comprehensible input
I believe this mini story idea which
started with Blaine Ray was then picked
up by AJ hole picked up by picked up by
filter in real polish PL which is where
I first discovered it and now I want to
make this available in as many languages
as possible with the help of volunteers
who either help us translate stories or
possibly there are people out there who
are creative and are willing to try to
create these stories in their own
language and also provide us with an
English translation so we could include
these and if you are willing to do that
then let me know and I'll send you this
description of the five levels and yeah
maybe we can move the project forward so
thank you for listening
[Music]